.
"THE FIVE."
♪ ♪
PRESIDENT BIDEN NOT DONE
ATTACKING UP THE COUNTRY WITH
NINE WEEKS TO GO UNTIL THE
MIDTERM ELECTIONS.
THE NASTY WORDS KEPT SPILLING
OUT AS JOE HIT THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL OVER THE LABOR DAY
WEEKEND.
BUT I EVEN COMING UP WITH A NEW
NICKNAME FOR HIS POLITICAL FOES.
>> NOT EVERY REPUBLICAN IS MAAG
ARE REPUBLICAN, NOT EVERY
REPUBLICAN GROUP EMBRACES THAT
EXTREME IDEOLOGY BUT I KNOW
BECAUSE I'VE BEEN ABLE TO WORK
WITH MAINSTREAM REPUBLICANS THE
WHOLE YEAR.
THE EXTREME MAGA REPUBLICANS IN
CONGRESS HAVE CHOSEN TO GO
BACKWARDS FULL OF ANGER,
VIOLENCE, HATE, DIVISION B OF
THE BIGGEST CONTRAST FROM WHAT
MAGA REPUBLICANS, THE EXTREME
RIGHT, THE TRUMPIES.
>> THE MEDIA IS RUNNING WITH
HIM.
>> THESE DAYS IT FEELS LIKE WE
ARE NOT JUST AT THE BRINK OF A
CIVIL WAR BUT ONE HAS ALREADY
BEGUN.
TRUMP SUPPORTER SIMILARLY BEGUN
SPEAKING THE LANGUAGE OF
VIOLENCE.
THIS IS TO DEFEND THEIR DEAR
LEADER.
>> IT'S A FASCIST MOVEMENT THAT
HAS EMBRACED WHITE NATIONALISM
AND WANTS TO IMPOSE ITS
RELIGIOUS BELIEFS.
IT'S AMERICANS VERSUS SPEED 12.
>> IT COULD BE MORE DANGEROUS
SINCE NINTH 1860.
IN 1861 THEY WERE DISPERSED BUT
THEY COULDN'T CONSPIRE TOGETHER
AND DECIDE HOW TO ATTACK THE
CAPITALS STATED ON THE
6TH OF JANUARY ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
>> JESSE WELCOME BACK.
I THINK WHAT WE SAW THERE IS WHY
HISTORIAN SHOULD NEVER BE ON
TWITTER.
HE'S NOT AS HE NOW SOUNDS LIKE A
FRESHMAN IN COLLEGE, HIS HAIR IS
ON FIRE PIT THAT SUPPOSED TO BE
A REPUTABLE HISTORIAN.
THERE ARE THREE HISTORIANS NOW
THAT ARE LOSING THEIR MINDS.
THEY'VE GONE CRAZY.
IT HAS TO BE SOCIAL MEDIA.
HOW DO YOU --
>> I LIKED ULTRA MAGA.
>> THEY ARE READING OFF THE SAME
TELEPROMPTER.
THEY'RE READING FROM THE SAME
SCRIPT BUT THE PEOPLE ARE NOT
BUYING IT.
DID YOU SEE JOE IN MILWAUKEE?
NOBODY HAD A JOB OR DIDN'T HAVE
ANYBODY ELSE TO GO AND DO.
YOU HAVE THE GUY THAT WON
80 MILLION VOTES, WHERE IS HIS
BASE?
WHERE ARE THE BIDEN VOTERS --
I'VE HAD MORE PEOPLE IN MY
BACKYARD AT A BARBECUE THEN WERE
AT THAT RALLY.
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
REDEFINE WHAT THE WORD RALLY
MEANS BECAUSE THAT WAS NOT A
RALLY.
EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT SOMETHING
FISHY IS GOING ON WITH THAT GUY.
GREG, WHEN YOU STINK AT
SOMETHING YOU HAVE TO POINT
FINGERS.
I'VE DONE IT MY WHOLE LIFE.
IT'S THE WHISKEY COME AS THE
PRODUCERS -- IF ONLY WE HAD A
GOOD QUARTERBACK.
IF THEY COULD JUST GIVE ME THE
BALL I WAS WIDE OPEN.
THAT'S WHAT YOU DO WHEN YOU
STINK AND THAT'S WHY PEOPLE THAT
STINK UP STUFF GO TO POLITICS.
THERE'S ALWAYS SOMEBODY TO
BLAME.
YOU CAN RUN THE ECONOMY INTO A
RECESSION THAT'S WHAT THEY WANT
TO HEAR.
IN A WAY POLITICS IS SO STUPID
YOU CAN SCREW THINGS UP AND
THROW RED MEAT TO YOUR BASE AND
THEN THEY CLAP.
BUT THE REPUBLICANS HAVE TO MEET
BIDEN HEAD ON.
IF THEY ARE BEING CALLED EXTREME
THIS IS WHAT YOU DO.
YOU GUYS WANT TO TALK ABOUT
TRANS GENDER, SEX EDUCATION AND
6-YEAR-OLDS.
YOU WANT THE 6-YEAR-OLDS WITH
MASKS ON AND YOU'RE TELLING THE
6-YEAR-OLDS WITH MASKS ON THEY
ARE ALSO RACIST AND THE SCHOOL
THEY ARE GOING TO IS ABE LINCOLN
ELEMENTARY AND WERE AT DEL MY
KEYS RACES SO WERE GOING TO
CHANGE THE NAME OF THAT AND IF
THEY COMPLAIN WORKING AWAY OR
TAP YOUR PHONE'S.
THEY WANT TO EMPTY THE PRISONS
AND OPEN UP THE BORDER AND POWER
THE ECONOMY WITH WINDMILLS.
GOD IS LOOKING DOWN AT LAUGHING
AT THEM PRETTY BUT THE OIL IN
THE GROUND.
HE DOESN'T WANT THE WIND TO
POWER, IT'S STUPID.
>> I WOULDN'T USE THAT ARGUMENT
BUT GO AHEAD.
>> WIND IS FOR BIRDS, THEN HE
COMES OUT AND STARTS BRIBING
LIBERALS WHO WENT TO LAW SCHOOL
WITH $10,000 CHECKS.
THEY GET OUT OF LAW SCHOOL AND
THEY CANNOT DEFINE WHAT A WOMAN
IS AND HE PUT THEM ON THE
SUPREME COURT.
GREG, THIS GUY IS INSANE.
HE JUST CAME OUT AND SAID THAT
REPUBLICANS ARE A THREAT TO
DEMOCRACY.
THIS IS THE GUY IN THE FBI THE
JUST RAKE THE LAST ELECTION AND
THEN RATED HIS POLITICAL
OPPONENTS HOUSE.
TRUMP GOT IMPEACHED FOR ASKING
TO INVESTIGATE JOE BIDEN.
JOE BIDEN ACTUALLY IS
INVESTIGATING DONALD TRUMP.
NOBODY'S TALKING ABOUT ABUSE OF
POWER.
WHY ARE THEY TALKING ABOUT IT,
GREG?
BECAUSE THEY ARE READING FROM A
TELEPROMPTER.
>> I JUST LIKE THE YOU KEEP
SAYING MY NAME.
HE NEVER USED TO DO THAT.
DANA, I WAS GOING TO ASK YOU
ABOUT HOW THE REPUBLICAN SHOULD
RESPOND.
THEY ARE DOING SOMETHING RIGHT.
THEY ARE STOKING FEAR.
THEY'RE ALSO TRYING TO TAKE THE
CRIME ISSUE AWAY FROM THE
REPUBLICANS PRESSING IF YOU
DON'T CONDEMN JANUARY 6TH HOW
CAN YOU BACK THE FLU?
SHOULD THE REPUBLICANS BE GOING
HEAD-ON WITH A CRIME STUFF WHEN
THE STATS ARE BOLSTERED IN EVERY
DAY WE HEAR TERRIBLE STORIES
ABOUT CRIMINALS AND RECIDIVISM?
>> Dana: IT'S AMAZING THAT
WITHIN A MONTH YOU HAVE THE
REPUBLICANS LOOK LIKE THEY HAD
THE MIDTERM ELECTION ON THE
SILVER PLAN ARE.
NOW A MONTH LATER WE ARE SITTING
HERE GOING I THINK A PART OF
THIS IS MEDIA NARRATIVE IN THE
PART OF IT IS PEOPLE THERE IS A
REALITY THAT REPUBLICANS ON A
COUPLE OF DIFFERENT ISSUES, ONE
BEING THE ABORTION ISSUE.
THEY HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
ON OFFENSE AND CONTINUE TO TALK
ABOUT EXTREMES.
THAT IS -- IT'S AN UGLY DEBATE
BUT IT MIGHT BE THE TRUTH THOUGH
WE ALL NEED TO TALK ABOUT
BECAUSE REPUBLICANS ARE GOING TO
BE ACCUSED OF ASKING FOR A BAND
WHEN THEY MAY BE NOT APPEAR
NOBODY IS GOING BACK TO THEM AND
SING BUT YOU'RE OKAY WITH
KILLING BABIES UP UNTIL THE
NINTH MONTH?
HOW CAN THAT BE?
THE OTHER THING ABOUT
JOE BIDEN'S IF YOU ARE IN YOUR
FARE IF THEY HAVE TRYING TO
EXPLAIN WHAT YOU MEANT IN YOUR
DEATH STAR SPEECH AND WHO YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT THEN YOU CAN HAVE
A WHOLE LINEUP LIKE YOU WERE IN
THAT GROUP, YOU'RE NOT IN THAT
GROUP, YOU'RE IN THAT GROUP --
THEY'RE CONSTANTLY HAVING TO DO
THAT.
NOBODY IS TALKING ABOUT THE NEXT
STEP FOR THEM GET THERE JUST
TALKING ABOUT HOW WEIRD THE
TACTIC IS.
I DO THINK THE REPUBLICANS HAVE
TO THINK ABOUT SOMETHING PRONTO.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW, JUDGE,
DANA, AS WELL AS OTHER NOTABLE
VOICES, HAS POINTED OUT THE
CONTRAST BETWEEN WHAT HAPPENS ON
SOCIAL MEDIA ON CABLE NEWS
VERSUS REALITY.
THESE PEOPLE BELIEVE THERE IS A
CIVIL WAR GOING ON BUT YOU GO
OUTSIDE AND TALK TO YOUR
NEIGHBOR, YOU GO TO STARBUCKS
AND LIFE JUST GOES ON.
IT'S LIKE A WEIRD -- THEY NEED
YOU TO BELIEVE IN THIS WILL
BIZARRE FANTASY BECAUSE WITHOUT
IT THEY HAVE TO DEAL WITH
REALITY.
>> Jeanine: THEY WANT YOU TO
BELIEVE WE ARE AT EACH OTHER'S
THROATS AND KILLING EACH OTHER.
YOU GO OUT AND YOU GO TO
DUNKIN' DONUTS OR WHEREVER YOU
GO EVERYBODY IS OPENING THE
DOOR, IT DOESN'T MATTER WHAT
COLOR YOU ARE OR WHAT LEVEL YOU
ARE OUT.
EVERYBODY'S MORNING, MORNING,
MORNING.
I MEAN AMERICANS REALLY BUT MY
FAVORITE PART OF THE SPEECH IS
WHEN BIDEN SAYS THOSE
REPUBLICANS ARE TAKING US
BACKWARDS.
REALLY?
I THINK IT'S THE DEMOCRATS
TAKING US BACKWARDS BECAUSE WHEN
YOU LOOK AT CHILDREN IN TERMS OF
EDUCATION BECAUSE THE DEMOCRATS
WOULDN'T OPEN THE SCHOOLS, OR
SKILL KIDS ARE SUFFERING AND NOW
A HUGE PERCENTAGE IN TERMS OF
BROWN AND BLACK CHILDREN,
UNFORTUNATELY COMPARED TO
NEGATIVE KIDS AROUND THE WORLD,
ALSO THEY'RE SAYING -- THE
REPUBLICANS WANT TO GO
BACKWARDS, WE DON'T WANT TO GO
BACKWARDS.
I WANT TO GO BACKWARDS.
BECAUSE WHEN DONALD TRUMP LOVE
INFLATION WAS SOMETHING LIKE 2%,
1.2%.
THE ANSWER WAS $2.50 PER GALLON
PAY THE PRICE OF FOOD WAS
AFFORDABLE FOR MOST PEOPLE.
AND WE DIDN'T HAVE A RECORD
CRIME RATE LIKE WE HAVE RIGHT
NOW.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE PROBLEM IS
WITH THE PAST.
WE'VE HAD A GOOD FOR A PERIOD OF
TIME.
WERE IN A RIGHT NOW JOE BIDEN
COME OF THE MAN LOVES DIVISION.
HE IS THE DIVIDER IN CHIEF.
>> Greg: I'M SURE USE SHARE
SOME OF THE SAME FEELINGS AS WE
DO BUT WHAT MIGHT THAT BE.
>> Geraldo: IT'S GOOD YOU'RE
BACK.
THERE ARE FOUR POLITICAL,
PARTIES IN CONJURING UP THERE
ARE THE MUGGER REPUBLICANS,
THERE ARE THE MAINSTREAM
CONSERVATIVE REPUBLICANS THAT I
LARGELY GREW UP WITH AND SERVED
WITHIN CONGRESS, THERE ARE THE
PROGRESSIVE DEMOCRATS IN THE
PERIPHERY IN MY PARTY IN MY
MIND, THEN THERE ARE MODERATE
DEMOCRATS IN WHICH I LIKE TO
THINK I SAID.
ELECTIONS ARE ABOUT CHOICES.
YOU HAVE TO GIVE PEOPLE THE
CHOICE THAT THEY CAN ACCEPT AND
MOST CAMPAIGNS ARE ABOUT MOVING
THE COUNTRY FORWARD.
JUDGE, I APPRECIATE THE WAY YOU
DESCRIBE THAT.
WE WANT THOSE THINGS AGAIN.
CAMPAIGNS ARE ALWAYS ONE IN THE
MIDDLE PAIR THE CAMPAIGN THE
BEST ATTRACTS INDEPENDENTS TO
THEIR SIDE AS THE CAMPAIGN THAT
IS LIKELIEST TO WIN.
PRESIDENT  -- FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP CALLED
PRESIDENT BIDEN AN ENEMY OF THE
STATE.
HE CALLED HIM THIS LAST WEEKEND
AND HE CALLED THE DOJ VICIOUS
MONSTERS.
I THINK PRESIDENT BIDEN SAID
AWFUL PERSONAL THINGS ABOUT MAGA
REPUBLICANS AND THEN TRIED TO
BACKTRACK A LITTLE BIT.
THIS IS THE ELECTION SEASON AND
THESE THINGS HAPPENS.
I HOPE THOSE IN POLITICS DON'T
GIVE UP ON PEOPLE.
I HEARD A GREAT COMMENTATOR OVER
THE WEEKEND MAKE THE POINT THAT
A LOT OF AMERICANS EXPERIENCE
PAIN AND DISAPPOINTMENT.
THEY EXPERIENCE UNREST AND
TURMOIL IN THEIR LIVES AND
POLITICIANS SOMETIMES SPEAK TO
THAT PAIN IN WAYS I SOMETIMES
WISH THEY WOULDN'T EVEN THOUGH
SOME ARE ON MY SIDE AND SOME ARE
NOT.
BUT WHEN ELECTIONS ARE OVER I
THINK ONE OF THE GREAT
SHORTCOMINGS OF OUR POLITICAL
SYSTEM WHICH IS OVERPROMISE AND
UNDER DELIVER NOW FOR 50 YEARS
BUT WHERE IT HAS REALLY FALLEN
IS THAT AFTER THE ELECTION
NOBODY'S ABLE TO GOVERN NOW
APPEARED WEATHERS DEMOCRATS IN
OPPOSITION, EVEN IF DEMOCRATS
CONTROL THE WHOLE THING, WHY?
BECAUSE THERE ARE FOUR PARTIES.
WE HAVE TO BEGIN NOT ONLY TO
SPEAK TO ONE ANOTHER BUT THERE
HAS TO BE A COMMITMENT TO
ACTUALLY WANT TO SOLVE PEOPLE'S
PROBLEMS.
EVEN IF WE DISAGREE YOU WANT TO
HAVE TO WANT TO SOLVE PEOPLE'S
PROBLEMS.
I THINK THE PART THAT DOES THAT
BEST IS GOING TO WIN THAT.
>> THAT'S WAY TOO NUANCED.
IT HAS TO BE US AND THEM.
YOU CANNOT DO US COME OF THEM,
US, THEM PURE THAT'S TOO
CONFUSING.
YOU CANNOT HAVE FOUR PARTIES.
>> Jesse: AND WHAT ABOUT
FASCISTS?
>> Greg: IS A SEMI FASCIST I
CALL YOU A SEMISOCIALIST.
ALL RIGHT COMING UP NEXT CHICAGO
MAYOR LORI LIGHT